what's up army Greg Alba John Humphrey a
cage on cook come on Greg monster we got
us commit to this keeping the continuity
going watch this video called BTS MV vs.
reality this is a topper war chair video
requests if it's not Natalie Dorne it's
gonna be Laura more oh we got two famous
army members in that she said it's
essentially a bunch of behind the scenes
clips from BTS music videos but it's
edited alongside the scenes from the
actual videos pretty much a gag reel but
also really cool way to see some of the
sets and has the original clip so even
if there's stuff from music videos you
haven't seen you can still understand
what the references are happy October
we've always pondered how it goes down
and these music videos and so it's cool
to see some behind the scenes you had
our patreon we do weekly Q&A s and TV
show reaction stream along some shows
the reaction highlights included and
this guy does music video reactions
about three times a week you best
believe kpop is infused in there quite a
bit let's get to it
[Music]
definitely wasn't leaders crisp
[Music]
drunk
[Music]
yeah that's a really cool guys don't
react to explosions even
oh damn how they do this what I wanted
to see like when you think
[Music]
[Music]
slip that bug
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Hey
[Music]
but so half their job is just having to
not react to all the craziness around
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
they did that Wow that's exactly how I
thought
[Music]
[Music]
saw
[Music]
where's massage right get that protein
[Music]
these guys don't work he's not follow
the time everything I thought about them
is alarm ship it never sleeps he's just
coming up with a song
[Music]
I guess they don't move as fast as a
framerate
[Music]
Oh
skill I and I should get better it's
always impressive
[Music]
the great archery course is near here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that look like me out there
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
in reality his feet are cold
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
reality is no room all by himself
[Music]
there's so much of the day there
probably
[Music]
[Music]
welcome
[Music]
it's a classic puppy
make sure it's there I got a get
comfortable enough to do the kind of
dance papers where I grab my crotch yeah
man
you guys just find your own way into it
everybody finds their own crotch grab
you just gotta feel your way to it I've
noticed that when I whip it out mm-hmm
but don't touch it somehow that's more
off-putting than me touching it over my
pants for a brief second um yeah I can I
can fathom that yeah and I'm not
touching it so I don't understand what
the big deal is mm-hmm yeah I mean I get
where you're coming from
it'sit's arguably a less suggestive act
but you know in some ways it's you know
try in here really try house the most
interesting sliced together behind the
scenes video Herzing these were like
true fly-on-the-wall moments it was like
watching vines if somebody disseminated
an entire behind-the-scenes documentary
via vine it would look something like
that it's like the song plan of you like
oh here's the bar and a half so that I
can get just enough into it to all okay
well here's a cute moment yes I mean we
got watch some like real
behind-the-scenes stuff but it's so cool
whenever I see how human these guys are
yeah even on these music video sets but
especially like the deep ones the ones
that seem like that are so heavy and the
emotional pouring the gasoline around
yeah hitting someone you know you always
imagine that they take it so seriously
when they're on set but they're so in
the moment and they really they're
believing this scene so when they ever
they say cut or break you're like oh
never mind they're not as intense yeah
capturing it in camera will happen to
believe they are they don't naturally
exist in the demeanor that they are off
and in in their songs and music video
yeah yeah yeah it's funny to watch them
be like oh with this thing that's gonna
look so poetic and so heavy be like I'm
just gonna whack around yeah yeah it's
odd because it's fun and it's funny but
then I wonder how I'm gonna feel the
next time I see a very serious music and
what's cool is you know I always love
seeing the process of
when you capture something from the from
the eye of the camera the perspective of
whatever the camera is how that just
makes everything look so different and
feel different coursers you know post
effects that go into this and there's
editing and whatnot and having the
actual good audio of the song over
playing a lot of variables but it's
funny how something can look so cool and
framed some of these behind-the-scenes
moments are not even really showing you
anything other than just a different
angle from a not as nice camera oh yeah
here's what it was like from a point of
view onset yeah you can see that some
things are built on sound stages you see
the the backsides of the really nice set
you're like okay like yeah this was just
constructed for this and I'm sure the
set itself they didn't spare any expense
to construct but yeah it is interesting
because the illusion of the music videos
is so strong and is so unified and so
polished yeah that it is funny to see
cuz especially for those higher class
ones or even the dingy ones it's funny
both ends of the spectrum sort of make
you think they must have just rented
like in a steep somewhere to nest or run
down truckstop bathroom for this but
yeah it's like there's so much movie
magic and I gotta imagine that they
acting the side is interesting because
it's different from silent movie acting
what's kind of silent acting because a
lot of time you're not running sound at
all I imagine the headspace you have to
get into in a way is altogether
different because in some ways it is
more physical you have to emote and
express more beyond you know just the
dancing scenes and whatnot but then I'm
sure there also other times where you
can be completely out of character but
doing something that looks just as good
you know so yeah that seems like a
fascinating place to work well this is
really cool thank you Laura first
suggestion is throwing the star away my
dear this is what our music videos are
gonna be like yeah mm-hmm my spoken word
music videos
that's right but there's gonna be a
whole plot line and a lot of deep
symbolism it's gonna be good Laura what
do you look like here's her profile
photo on patreon but what do you look
like
why must you hide your face I've had
about two people get upset at me for
showing their face from patreon over
yeah I thought like their faces here
they're gonna feel honored for showing
their face about two people have gotten
upset and your face is not fully shown
so here's hoping you're not the third
hope he stills they /youtube edit
feature